the Game of Thrones Season 6 trailer is
finally out and combined with a bunch of
promo stills and hints from the books we
can predict a lot of the big events of
the upcoming season so let's have a look
the trailer starts at the wall with the
body of Jon Snow who was stabbed to
death by his fellow Knights watchman at
the end of the last season and book it
looks like there's a conflict over Jon's
corpse Davos uses John's sword to fight
some nights Watchmen and we see some
Watchmen trying to break through a
locked door we also see the red witch
Melisandre lurking around and talking to
Davos it looks like The Watchmen are
trying to stop Mel doing something to
John's body probably some magic that
will lead to John's resurrection there
are heaps of hints for John's return in
the books and in the show and it's
believed that John's direwolf ghost
might be involved so it's telling that
we see the wolf by John side in the
trailer later we see a battle known as
bastard Bowl beginning between the
Bolton's on one side and the other
Northman with the wildlings out from the
wall on another tormund is there Ramsay
is probably there and we even see
someone who looks suspiciously like John
also near Winterfell we see Sansa and
Theon fleeing from the Bolton's and it
looks like they get caught by a Bolton
man with dogs but then Brienne appears
kills the man and presumably saves them
Sansa little looks like she's in a safe
situation maybe with Brienne or the
Northman though Littlefinger looks like
he's lurking up there too so she might
end up with him point is Sansa Theon
Brienne and Littlefinger may also get
caught up in this massive conflict in
the north they'll certainly be deaths
maybe torment hopefully Ramsay though it
looks like he's got at least 20 good men
there so he's probably unstoppable
anyway in Braavos we see that aya is
still blind and she spent some time
begging as blind Beth she's still at the
house of black and white though she
seems to have a falling out with her
magical assassin Frantz the faceless men
one of them the wife hits her and we
later see aya leaping off a rooftop
maybe running away from the waif this
might indicate that Isle leaves the
faceless men may be returning to
Westeros where she has some unfinished
business the further east the city of
murine is left in the hands of a dwarf
an ex-slave
and two eunuchs which sounds like the
start of some terrible joke there's a
shot of an explosion of the Great
Pyramid which maybe could be caused by
the sons of the harpy who continued
resist Danny's rule we also see Tyrion
in some dark underground location which
could be the pyramid basement where two
of Danny's dragons who locked up maybe
this is how the Dragons get released
while Tyrion and Co try to keep things
under control in Mereen Daario and Jorah
head off to look for Dany who was last
seen flying out of the city on the back
of drag on one of Joris fingernails has
visibly gone black which indicates the
spread of the nasty disease Jorah caught
from the stone man in Valyria it'll be
interesting to see if anyone finds out
about his condition which is both deadly
and contagious anyway it looks like
Danny is captured by Dothraki and we see
her being taken to what looks like Vaes
Dothrak as sort of a sacred city to the
Dothraki so things might look bad for
Dany but she's got a drug or next
machina coming her way so she'll
probably be okay by the time Jorah and
Daario find her she'll likely have made
a bloody barbeque of a Dothraki captors
back in Westeros we see a new player
arrive at the Iron Islands a ship sails
in on a stormy sea bringing in the
infamous pirate euron greyjoy who for
some reason doesn't have an eyepatch
despite being you know the crow's eye
the quintessential badass pirate king
but anyway we see you're on standing on
a bridge in a storm which is probably
where he kills his brother bail on which
leads to the Kings moat an election of
sorts whether iron men choose their new
king this could be a really cool scene
with a Ron damp hair Asha or Yara
Greyjoy and the crows are all duking it
out though sadly there's apparently no
Victorian in King's Landing Jaime has an
awkward sort of a honey I'm home moment
bringing the body of Marcelo back to
Cersei in the books Jaime and Cersei are
pretty well broken up at this point but
here they catch up on some incest and
Jaime promises to help win back her
power their enemies are the faith the
high Sparrow and his followers who seem
determined to bring down the Lannisters
silver throne Empire the faith seems to
still have Margaery imprisoned and it
looks like the Tyrells try to get her
back the wild-card in this conflict is
Robert strong the reanimated Gregor
Clegane made by Qyburn to serve Cersei
as an eight-foot-tall monstrous zombie
mountain we can be pretty certain that
Bobby strong will rechtshaid up this
season she's violent but if rumors
proved true the silent giant might be
stopped by his brother the Hound
turned from the grave at the end of the
trailer we see bran standing in the snow
turning around and seeing the night king
the apparent leader of the White Walkers
this isn't actually happening for
realsies it's a sort of a vision
remember bran is hanging out with this
creepy old tree man called the
three-eyed crow aka Brynden rivers aka
bloodraven who's recently been recast
and who's teaching him to use the magic
of the old gods which involves seeing
through the eyes of weirwood trees all
across long distances and even back in
time bran uses this magic to have
visions of the present and the past and
so this thing with the White Walkers
looks like it's one of those what's
really exciting though are these shots
of what looks to be the fight at the
Tower of joy an event that book readers
have been obsessing over for literally
20 years ever since the first book came
out this is something that happened
towards the end of Robert's rebellion an
epic fight with a young Eddard Stark and
six of his men against three famous
Kingsguard Knights including the
legendary Arthur Dayne but more
important than the fight itself is its
aftermath where edad makes a promise to
his dying sister Lyanna which is
believed to relate to the birth of Jon
Snow this scene could lead to the reveal
of one of the biggest oldest secrets in
Game of Thrones the true parentage of
Jon Snow so that's the trailer he got
the resurrection of Jon Snow bastard
bowl are you going rogue and conflict in
Mereen you got your Dothraki barbecue
you Kingsmoot possibly click game Bowl
and finally after all these years the
Tower of joy the season looks like it's
going to be awesome so make sure to
subscribe to old chief decks for more
explanations and analysis throughout the
series we've already got videos out on I
use character arc Danny's future path
grayscale euron greyjoy
Robert strong the return of the Hound R
+ L equal Jay Jon's resurrection and
much more so check those out if you can
and expect many more videos throughout
season 6 and beyond thank you for
watching and many thanks to all the
patrons supporting this channel
including an asura Ponty Benny Vasquez
Lamarr ronzo Madison Richland Amy
McDermott Julia Storch Lesley Ann Davis
Nikki Wouter van Strahl and JV Justin
bull handler Sondra Benjamin arson Seth
tops - penny blue margaritas Cena three
things down snow Henry Cooper and Dick
Johnson thanks again and see you next
time